ciao ragazzi allora faccio questa
piccolissima introduzione prima della
recensione per dirvi una cosina veloce
vorrei che muoio vorrei che andasse a
vedere se vi va il video che c'è come
video e risposto a questa recensione è
un video nel mio secondo canale in cui
parlo del progetto diciamo progetto tra
virgolette delle magliette delle
recensioni
so che molti di voi in molti di voi le
aspettavano e le volevano quindi se
volete se siete interessati volete
saperne di più ne parlo in un video
apposito proprio per non rompere le
palle alla recensione
finisco qui ripeto il video enel come
video dispone su come video disposto a
questo qui è niente spero che la
recensione nuovo vi piaccia e ci vediamo
dopo
salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale e
il canale dei casco brothers due ragazzi
veramente simpaticissimi che fanno video
divertenti che saluto tra l'altro ciao
ragazzi il link come al solito nella
descrizione del video iscrivetevi perché
ne vale la pena
detto questo anche se oggi ho una voce
che ricorda un transessuale brasiliano
iniziamo il film che voglio recensire
oggi è cryptozoic un horror movie del
1987 diretto da david le cote credo sia
francese
il film è dato come low budget però c'è
low budget per gli standard americani
perché il suo budget ed è stato 150.000
dollari
e se posso permettermi di descrivere
questo film con una sola parola e kakà
quindi la recensione finisce qui spero
vi sia piaciuta
io vi ringrazio come al solito di tutti
i commenti di tutti i complimenti che mi
fate e ci vediamo nella prossima
recensione
volete
fondi scala recensione vabbè io
l'avvertimento velo dato è che gli ho
fatto finire la recensione prima poi non
datemi la colpa se non avete spento se
non avete chiuso la finestra di youtube
prima non datemi la colpa
e allora vediamo insieme quali sono i
cinque punti per cui credo zoid potrebbe
benissimo essere usato come pena
capitale per gli stati uniti
numero 5 la trama il film ambientato nel
sei anni dopo una guerra nucleare che ha
distrutto tutto il mondo wow originale
un gruppo di sopravvissuti vaga per il
mondo ad un certo punto sta per mettersi
a piovere siccome dopo le guerre
nucleari e la pioggia è acida loro si
nascondono in un palazzo scoprono che
questo palazzo era un laboratorio
segreto per gli esperimenti del governo
egli dentro si trovano delle schifezze
alier è esatto non è una trama per nulla
originale
la cosa che mi ha dato più fastidio però
è che non rendono bene il post
apocalittico per niente notate come post
nucleare quel muro oppure quella strada
lasciamo perdere è il vincitore per la
scena di nudo più veloce nella storia
dei vip e grippo zoid ieri dopo soli
cinque minuti di film dopo cinque minuti
di film già la prima scena di nudo anche
possiamo conoscere i personaggi già li
vediamo lui va beh almeno la legge la
siamo tolta subito dalle palle
numero 4 giu
la regia di questo film è strana molto
strana
il regista pensa che se tu fai le scene
al rallentatore aumenta la tensione
no ogni volta che loro ispezionano un
cunicolo che devono aprire una porta che
devono camminare in un corridoio lo
voglio con una lentezza in proprio non
funziona nonno e questo rende tutto
noiosissimo
avete presente quando i vostri amici
tornano dalle vacanze vi dicono a guarda
con la fotocamera ho fatto 400 mila foto
del viaggio e 200 mila miliardi di
minuti di video da farti vedere se è
contento
avete presente come in quelle situazioni
non me ne frega assolutamente nulla di
quello che loro hanno visto di quello
che loro hanno fatto in quel momento voi
vorreste fare tutt'altro tipo suicidarvi
ecco quello è molto ma molto più
divertente di guardare questo film
e una porta non ti morde tranquilla
numero 3 pupazzo it o preparate la
vostra mente per il costume dalle iene o
più bello che abbiate mai visto in vita
vostra
questo è quello che hanno tirato fuori
da 150mila dollari
esatto un nemico dei power rangers
pensate la delusione to aspetti due ore
che una persona riesca ad andare ad
aprire una dannata porta per poi trovare
di sto schifo
delusione e lo stai facendo nel modo
giusto almeno hanno avuto il cervello di
farlo vedere quasi sempre in penombra
così non si capisce nulla
ad un certo punto come se non bastasse
il costume dell'alieno principale arriva
un topo un topo che non c'entra quasi
niente con la storica tu sia un dopo
infetto perché è un po più grande del
resto degli animali diciamo gerundo però
non c'entra niente con l'alieno c'è un
topo nei laboratori un topo
probabilmente ci avranno fatto gli
esperimenti sopra ma non lo dicono
quindi me lo invento io
siete pronti no voi siete fortunati
perché alla visione di questo non
avevamo preparato a nessuno
un peluche e un fottutissimo peluche ma
non è che poi ogni cosa che tu prendi la
muovi verso il tuo collo sembra che ti
stia attaccando è questo fumetto di
repubblica di superman mi sto attaccando
non funziona così
ho il mio ha ucciso bruges assassina
numero due
scene d'azione la prima volta che
l'alieno la mutazione l'esperimento quel
che è visto che non lo spiegano attacca
succede una cosa un po strana viene
attaccato uno dei protagonisti però poi
gli amici lo ritrovano in buonissime
condizioni allora qui c'è qualcosa sotto
ed infatti lui dopo un po inizia a
trasformarsi e così gli avrà depositato
le uova dentro gli avrà spruzzato
qualcosa addosso per farlo puoi
trasformare in alieno un classico
processi e morto e allora cosa è servito
perché non l'ha ucciso subito all'alieno
film qualche spiegazione nulla nulla non
hai ben che minimo senso laniero spruzza
questa sostanza addosso alle persone che
dopo un po si gonfiano sfruttano il loro
sangue e muoiono ma scusa cieli delle
sciabole gigantesche lì perché perché
non is much unico le sciabole magari
sarebbero venute delle scene più carine
no vabbè anche la psicologia dei
protagonisti mi ha lasciato stupito in
senso negativo ovviamente
ecco i due protagonisti alle prese con
la mutazione
e una cosa la vedi questa ne hai tu una
in mano uguale lo vedi questo si chiama
grilletto
questa parte di pistola se tuona punti
contro quello che ti sta facendo cagare
in mano etienne il grilletto esce
qualcosa da questa parte con una
fiammata che lo può uccidere perché ai
protagonisti dei film o ridivenuto date
armi che poi non usano sarebbe biologico
dargli un palo di legno ma questi sono
marin qualche addestramento militare ce
l'avranno
ok [ __ ] provato
odio la mia vita ma dai calcio perfino
alex l'ariete sapeva come usarla una
pistola a senti questa è una pistola
questo spara anche nella scena del dopo
quella che abbiamo visto prima guardate
appena appena arriva questo topo
mutaforma come reagiscono le due marin
andiamo a fare a pezzi qualche alieno
come uno scarafaggio
ma dio santa erano più coraggiosi fra i
ragazzi di questi qui poi è allora il
film è pieno zeppo di stronzate però ce
ne sono alcune che veramente sono fuori
da ogni schema mentale dopo che il topo
morde una delle due ragazze al collo e
poi lo uccidono arriva un altro dei
protagonisti cercano di aiutarla
sì sì se magari le coprite il buco sul
collo stanno sgorgando litri di sangue
che ho finalmente get a blanket prendi
una coperta ce l'hanno fatta ma no ma no
lì sul collo gliela devi mettere sta
morendo e della como per io che pensavo
che con deadly prey avremmo toccato il
fondo
numero 1 finale alla fine rimangono il
mega esperimento genetico è uno solo dei
protagonisti combatto combattono come
vedete in un magazzino pieno zeppo di
scatole e loro sono arrivati lì
completamente a caso rientrando in un
palazzo che non pensavano neanche fosse
un un laboratorio loro non sanno niente
di niente di questo posto
eppure la prima scatola a caso che il
protagonista prende dentro ci sono delle
siringhe e un liquido che non spiegano
cosa sia ma che per qualche ragione
sconosciuta iniettato nel corno
dell'area e no lo uccide comunque anche
se non spiegano che cacchio e il liquido
l'alieno si accascia a terra e muore ma
poi succede una cosa che io non mi sarei
mai aspettato e che non ho mai visto
prima dall'alieno fuoriesce un bambino
e lo so ragazzi non dovrei farlo ma lo
faccio lo stesso faccio delle domande
perché non hanno accennato al fatto che
l'alieno fosse incinta perché è uscito
un bambino ha a che fare con il liquido
che quello gli ha iniettato ma anche se
fosse stato un seme maschile in tre
secondi non nasce un bambino perché il
bambino è nato subito dopo che l'alieno
è morto perché io ho guardato questo
film
comunque il feto esce dall alieno e con
lentezza proposito tuo si muove verso il
protagonista sopravvissuto che invece di
scappare via da lì dove ci sono alieni
suoi compagni morti feti puzza ovunque
se ne sta accasciato in un angolo perché
perché se ne sta accasciato invece di
scappare perché io continuo a fare
domande di cui non avrò risposta e poi
c'è questa scena di lotta metà epica
devo dire perché non l'avevo mai vista
in italia invita ridicola perché fatta
veramente di merda tra il protagonista e
il bambino
oh mio dio il portafoglio mi sta
attaccando e se lo sfogo il più
possibile sembra vero ok basta così lui
scaraventa al bambino il bambino muore e
lui finalmente riesce a scappare
ehi che sorpresa c'è un finale a
sorpresa non me lo sarei mai aspettato
da un film squallido
io vi avevo avvertiti avevo cercato di
farvi spegnere la recensione subito non
mi avete ascoltato ora voi siete
costretti a guardarvelo sta schifezza
perché non voglio essere l'unico al
mondo ad aver visto questa schifezza
però volete sapere l'unica nota positiva
di questo film l'attrice protagonista
che fa quella scena di nudo rapidissima
è diventata un'attrice porno
ma a parte quello fa tutto schifo quindi
io questo film non ve lo consiglio
perché nonostante i duri poco
bruttissime noiosissimo perché tu le
scene d'azione sono ridicole e vale
giusto la visione del topo pupazzo e
basta così
guardate quello con gli amici ma neanche
tanto perché anche anche con gli amici
non rende tantissimo io come al solito
vi ringrazio per tutti i complimenti di
tutti i commenti che mi lasciate e ci
vediamo la prossima recensione